so we just got some fresh leaks
concerning the long-awaited apple tv6
which i'm super excited about because
they help confirm
my speculations from last year but on
the other hand
we have some negative news as well
that's a bit disappointing
to say the least so in this video i'm
gonna go through all of those leaks
both the good and the bad to basically
show you guys what you should be
expecting
when apple releases the new apple tv and
also what you can expect in the future
because based on these leaks it should
be
very exciting but before i get into the
most recent
groundbreaking leaks i want to give you
guys a full rundown
on when these leaks originally started
and how they're now all compounding
together
to make all of this very possible so
let's get right into it the leak started
in the beginning of last year
with leaked tvos 13.4 beta code
showing brand new apple tv hardware in
the works
and then a month later ios 14 revealed
that there was a new apple tv remote
being worked on as well
which is important because everyone
hates the current apple tv remote
since it's extremely limiting and it's
not very reliable
then later in march the verifier
reported that apple was planning to
launch a new apple tv
with up to 128 gigs of storage they also
mentioned that tv os would be upgraded
with kids mode screen time and
better parental controls then in april 9
to 5 max said that a trusted source
claimed that the apple tv will be coming
with an a14
chip the same one that's in the iphone
12 and the ipad air 4.
and then in may john prosser said that
an apple tv with an a12x chip
the same chip that came in the 2018 ipad
pro would be launching very soon
but that obviously didn't happen so i
wonder why apple has been continuing to
hold off for so long
jumping way ahead to august bloomberg
reported that a new apple tv is in the
works
with an upgraded remote and a new find
my apple tv remote feature
which is very exciting and it means that
it's getting some sort
of tracking chip built into it and then
in october
fudge a fairly reliable leaker on
twitter claimed that apple arcade is
getting
big money poured into it he said that
new titles are in development that are
so huge
that they're meant to rival games like
zelda breath of the wild
now if that's true then that would make
sense why apple is waiting
so long to release the apple tv they're
probably planning
a huge gaming push but they need the
games to be ready first
and big aaa titles take years to develop
fudge also claimed that there are two
apple tv models in the works
one with an a12x slash z chip and a
higher end model with an a14x like champ
he again confirmed the reports of a new
controller and he even said that there
are some crazy
aaa games coming that will require the
a13 bionic and up to run
which basically means very graphically
intensive games
now what makes the rumors of two
different apple tv models very
interesting
is the fact that in 2018 there were
rumors of an apple tv dongle in the
works
which would compete with google's
chromecast ultra
that would actually make a lot of sense
because the dongle could be the lower
end model
for basic apple tv movie and show
streaming
but the higher end model could be
specifically for
gaming and it could potentially come
with a gaming controller bundled with it
moving on on october 3rd it was reported
that an apple tv
with an a14xlike chip was sent out to
game developers for testing
so it shows that those new aaa games are
already in the works
and they require a ton of graphics power
to run
which is extremely exciting and then on
october 11th
john prosser said that the new apple tv
will have a u1 chip
to track the location of your iphone
within your home
so it can automate tasks like
controlling the brightness or sound
or maybe even do things like lock your
smart door lock
if you leave and he also believes that
the u1 chip will be a huge part of the
apple ecosystem
and he expects most apple products in
the future to come with one of these
chips
that has already been in the iphone
since last year's 11 pro
now moving on to december nikkei
reported that we should be getting a new
apple tv
sometime in 2021 but they didn't mention
any specific
dates then later that month bloomberg
once again confirmed that we're still
getting a new apple tv
with an updated remote in 2021 and they
mentioned that it's gonna have a
stronger
gaming focus saying that there's going
to be a big leap
in terms of hardware and software to
remain
competitive in the long term this goes
to show that apple is planning something
big for this new apple tv pushing into
the gaming segment and that's probably
why it's taking so long
and we can for sure expect a very
powerful chip
like the a14x and now getting into the
most
recent groundbreaking leaks left a dream
posted some images of the current apple
tv remote
with a tagline saying it's time to
change
once again confirming that a new remote
will be coming with the new tv
so just by looking at all of those leaks
and rumors
we should be getting extremely excited
however
there is still some very bad news that
we gotta cover
so let's get into that many people were
hoping for a release date
this march but we just got a major new
rumor to date from
the verifier apparently this new apple
tv
is actually coming later this year in
the fourth quarter
which means between october and the end
of the year they say that apple will be
hosting a special
apple tv plus event where they will
reveal some new movie and show content
as well as the new tv os 15 features
like a major software design
refresh a better app store ui a new kids
mode with better parental controls and
channel subscription bundles
so based on those most recent rumors
it's a bit sad to see that the apple tv
could be launching way later than we
expected
but there could actually be a very good
reason for it
the verifier claim that apple is in
advanced talks
with major and well-known gaming
companies
in order to offer their games outside of
the xbox
playstation and pc consoles this
basically means that apple is trying to
get
aaa game developers to bring their games
to the apple tv
and potentially more apple products so
if we can get some awesome
aaa titles to the apple tv it'll greatly
help apples push into the gaming market
so it's going to be worth spending tons
of cash just on game development and
getting
ports over to the apple tv this is
extremely exciting because it opens up
the possibility
of cross-platform play which is
basically required
if you want to have a competitive gaming
console these days
they also mentioned that there would be
a new apple remote as well as an actual
dedicated gaming controller which will
probably be an
optional add-on we actually saw various
leaks and rumors about a dedicated
controller coming
and it falls in line with apple's recent
software updates
which added major controller features
like button remapping
better haptics and rumble showing that
apple was planning to get big into
gaming very soon now with all of those
leaks and rumors out of the way let me
speculate on what apple is planning to
do
and how they can pull off the apple tv
launch first off if they truly are
planning to delay the release date
until the end of the year this points to
apple waiting on the rumored
aaa games to be ready before launching
the apple tv
this shows that they want all of their
cards to fall into place
before making the big launch and this
gives them
more time to make deals with major game
developers as well
if apple does reveal a new gaming
controller
for the apple tv there's a good chance
that they will open up tv os
to natively play ipad games as well
since the ipad now has really good
controller support
and apple did add crossplay gaming
features
in the latest 14 series of os updates
now one thing i want to mention is that
during apple's iphone 12 event
they showed off league of legends wild
rift which i can see coming with
controller support
so this means that this game will likely
be supported on the apple tv as well
so you'll basically be able to use the
new controller on any apple device
which i think is the ultimate goal and
i'm basically 100
sure that the new diablo immortal game
will be coming to the apple tv as well
what'll make this awesome is the fact
that you'll be able to play these games
on your apple tv
then your iphone your ipad and now even
your mac and your progress is going to
be auto saved
using game center so you have a complete
gaming ecosystem
now i personally hope that this apple tv
will be launching a bit
earlier like in march since that's when
we're expecting the a14x chip to be
released
but apple could totally wait until the
end of the year
if the games aren't ready right now now
as far as the price tag i expect the
apple tv hd replacement model
to start between 99 and 149
depending on if it's gonna be a dongle
or not and for the higher end model
i think it could be priced as high as
279 to 349 dollars
because it's going to be competing with
the other gaming consoles
and it's gonna offer a ton of
performance so there you guys go
hopefully you enjoy this video and if
you disagree with any of my speculation
go ahead and comment down below and
click the circle above to subscribe
for more videos like this one definitely
check out one of those two videos right
there
thanks for watching and we'll see you in
the next video